the joy of making sells renaud maladies
deals in used clothes from Uganda's
capital Kampala he has done this for
more than 20 years so what do you from
here I've managed to save and build
houses to buy several stalls I did not
have any of these things when I was
starting I've educated my children and
sent some of them to university but his
main source of income is threatened
government wants to ban in petition of
used clothes saying the frustrate the
local textile industry second-hand
clothes are common especially among the
poor who cannot afford the same quality
of clothes
when they are new research shows that 8
out of 10 Africans have worn a used
garment right now I can buy clothing for
as little as one thousand shillings
which is below half a US dollar if you
say you want a ban use clothes
it's disturbing because there's
literally no alternative some you canons
dealing in new clothes say imported used
clothes at cheap which makes local
products non competitive they have
welcomed government's plans it's a lot
of sense of course as someone who owns a
fashion happens who makes clothes
I want my clientele to grow I want my
business to grow I want you know to get
more customers every year uganda imports
over 1,500 tons of used clothes from the
united states alone and as a mainly
imported from Europe the global
secondhand clothing trade among leading
exporters is valued at above 1.7 billion
dollars but as this trade remains
lucrative across the world thousands of
Ugandan traders like Mary Z remain
uncertain for their livelihood
you